[Music]  from the heartland of north america  comes the story of a hidden paradise  discover a wetland oasis  vital to millions of birds  fly alongside the epic migrations of  these remarkable creatures as they  return home to raise the next generation  is this  you are the wind underneath my wings you  got me higher than i've ever been  when i'm with you i'm flying  when i'm with you i'm flying  meet the diverse wildlife that all play  a part in this bountiful ecosystem  [Music]  and join the inspiring people working to  protect it  [Music]  soar across the prairie wetlands and  learn why we all need wide open spaces  to spread our wind  when i'm with you on fly  narrated by me  michael keaton  coming soon  [Music]